this looks like a sinkhole to the abyss
and it eats garbage this is like all
brilliant inventions because it's
amazingly simple and always makes you
think why didn't I think of that so how
does this garbage gadget help clean up
the oceans Andrew and Pete have created
something really cool it's basically a
filtration system it sits in the water
it's a tiny little bucket and it's got a
filter in it when they put the see bend
in the water there's just air inside and
the lip of the see bin is just below the
water's level now the ad is in the bin
is a lower pressure to the water around
it so the sea water rushes over the top
to equalize that pressure once the water
flows into the bin they've got a pump
that's pumping that water out and it's
onshore it's a continuous cycle water is
constantly flowing and getting filtered
and then pumped back into the sea the
way larger pieces of trash are filtered
out is that in that bin in the water
there's a natural fiber bag the water &
trash mixture flows into that bag the
water flows through the bottom but the
trash stays that bag can be easily
removed from the seabed and can be
disposed of or recycled the sea bin is
waving goodbye to saltwater trash
you